[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on peut apprécier l'économie on peut
aimer l'économie il ne suffit pas
d'aimer pour bien la décrypter
[Musique]
oui cette inflation un impact sur le
panier de la ménagère et sur le coup de
vie en général
moi je diminue la température de
chauffage on fait avec on essaie de
gérer le budget au mieux et puis c'est
vrai que c'est pas facile mais bon on
s'adapte
je pense qu'il faudrait peut-être que
les gens et apprennent à vivre d'une
manière différente surtout ça je crois
qu'il faut qu'il faut changer ses
habitudes moi j'ai arrêté de prendre ma
voiture par exemple et la piscine elle
est à
une demi-heure de marche avant j'y
allais en voiture mais maintenant j'y
vais à pied
que faut-il faire dans une situation où
l'inflation commence à produire ses
effets et où on commence à ressentir les
effets de l'inflation le consommateur
généralement à l'occasion de ses achats
la possibilité de faire ce qu'on appelle
des arbitrages bien évidemment donc il
fait une sélection des produits en
fonction de ses besoins en fonction de
ses préférences et ensuite il compose
son panier de bien ou son panier d'achat
en période d'inflation ce qui se passe
c'est qu'il a l'impression qu'il en a
moins pour son argent donc il va devoir
tenir compte de l'évolution positive des
prix soit il va consommer moins il va se
restreindre considérant que c'est trop
cher soit il va remplacer un produit
courant qu'il avait l'habitude d'acheter
et il va descendre en gamme il va aller
vers des produits de moindre qualité
parce que ces produits sont moins chers
le prix a une fonction essentielle c'est
qu'il envoie de l'information il envoie
de l'information consommateur et
généralement le consommateur
un prix plus élevé et est un gage
généralement de qualité meilleure donc
le consommateur va essayer d'entrer dans
ce qu'on appelle cette cheap Fléchon
elle prend plus des billets en première
classe on va aller dans des compagnies
low cost premièrement est-ce que je peux
restreindre mes consommations oui s'il
s'agit de consommation je dirais de
tourisme de consommation de loisirs non
s'il s'agit de ce que l'on appelle des
dépenses contraintes c'est-à-dire je ne
peux pas du jour au lendemain annoncer à
la personne qui me loge que je vais
payer mon loyer un mois sur deux je ne
peux pas décider de moi-même de réduire
la facture de gaz simplement parce
qu'elle est trop cher je peux essayer de
restreindre ma consommation mais je ne
peux pas du jour au lendemain
restreindre la facture je peux me
tourner vers l'épargne les revenus
d'hier que je n'ai pas dépensé je les
épargné et bien aujourd'hui je vais les
chercher là encore c'est une possibilité
mais elle n'est que pour une certaine
frange de la population à partir des
classes moyennes on a des comportements
d'épargne en deçà ce dont les ressources
sont dépendantes à 50% des minima
sociaux on ne peut pas imaginer qu'ils
aient la possibilité de mettre quoi que
ce soit de côté entre guillemets et donc
pour eux se posent la question de
souscrire à des crédits le crédit à la
consommation enfin qui portent mal son
nom c'est ce qu'on appelle des crédits
fractionnés des crédits fractionnés sont
les paiements trois fois sans frais
c'est un crédit qui est autorisé pour de
faibles montants pas plus de 200 euros
et donc ça ne rentre pas dans la
catégorie d'égale des crédits mais
aujourd'hui ce que l'on voit c'est que
ces crédits sont sollicités des 50 euros
voire même des 30 euros d'achat et le
consommateur qui va dans cette boucle de
du crédit qui se lance dans ses crédits
on observe aussi que finalement sous
forme une forme d'addiction si on prend
le terme très fort au sens où il a
tendance à remplir un peu plus son
panier et le panier moyen est devint à
30% plus important lorsqu'on paye avec
ce crédit fractionné comparé à un
paiement comptant pourquoi et bien parce
que la facture est allégée payée une
somme en trois fois vous avez la fausse
sensation cette illusion de payer de
payer moins cher
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]